hey what's up guys my name is Jonah
welcome to episode 36 of game
programming so today we're going to be
doing something that you guys probably
wanted to do for the past I don't know
10 episodes and that is actually render
our tiles on onto the screen so what
we've got right now is you might think
we're rendering tiles onto the screen
but really we're not like we are but
we're using a method that we use
probably about 10 episodes ago and and
well it's just not the best method um as
we as we you know discover I guess um
but yeah the method that we're actually
using if we go into our game chav
alright so this is our main like there's
our main class because it's called a
main class because it contains our main
method which is which is what Java runs
when we run our application now in this
render method
this random method is the main random
method everything that's in this render
method is actually what gets routed onto
the screen so you can see that over here
we've got a line of code saying screen
render now if we follow that by hitting
holding down control and clicking I'm
using Eclipse by the ways of using
another IDE it might not be the same but
ctrl click on render we can see that
this is what we this is what we're using
to render was simply with just simply
rendering just grass right now okay
that's what we're doing so what I want
to do right now is delete that method
yep that's right I just deleted the
render with two integers as the
parameters I just deleted that method
from the screen class boom [ __ ] it's
getting real right now um and we'll also
get it out so now if we run our game
you'll find now that we're not actually
rendering anything and yeah so right now
we're going to actually render this
level render method and hopefully it'll
work as it should so first of all you
can see over here that we've actually
got the way that is actually rendering
is is if it's calling on the render
method inside the tile class so if we go
into our toggle class or specifically
let's just say a grass style class you
can see the worth doing is this calling
screen don't render tile and if we
followed that you can see that this is
what's rendering it so it is still
rendering something that's great it
works perfectly what should work don't
paper work perfectly um now I've
actually deliberately littered leaded a
few bugs around this around this joint
um just to show you guys like what
happens if you are you know if you use
like I don't know gets the wrong code if
you don't if you don't actually use your
mouths correctly if you don't figure out
the maths correctly what happens just
just so that you guys can consult of C
you know um in future if you make an
error and you'll be like oh I remember
that
um that's just because of this because
you'll you'll we'll see what the result
is because there are a lot of common
errors you make obviously so just keep
that in mind um but yeah so the way
we're going to do this is we're actually
going to call our levels this is the
level class we're actually going to call
our levels render method so over here in
game we first of all need to make a new
level so up here at the beginning I'm
going to type private level level
right and this is just going to be our
level right now now one thing you should
realize also is that you should only
have one level loaded at one point in
time okay
there's absolutely no point in having
two levels cached because you won't
actually you know you can't display two
levels at once our character can only be
on one level at one time if he goes to
another level and we switch levels but
we never have two levels running
parallel at the same time so we only
need one level object really and over
here in games this is a constructor I'm
just going to simply type level equals
new random level and then we'll give it
a size so let's just say 64 by 64 so
that's obviously in terms of tiles so
the our level size our random level size
will be 64 by 64 tiles now if we go down
here into our render method we're simply
going to call our levels render method
so level dot render and then you'll see
that we have three parameters to fill in
the extra little I scroll in the screen
so the X scroll will simply be now you
know our X our x and y variables will
read that we made up here so X Y and
screen will obviously be our screen
object and that's it that is it so let's
just right now let's just run and see
what happens alright so we actually got
an on pointer exception and that's
probably because a random yeah I'm
guessing randoms in all here um because
it's not static let's just make it
static right so static obviously means
that it sort of cache again we won't
actually need to have multiple random
objects so making a static can't hurt so
let's run that again everyone crash or I
didn't crash great now you can see on
our screen that we've well let's just
say we didn't get our desired result um
instead we got this now this is one of
the bugs that I you know didn't take out
um on purpose just to let you guys know
you know what it looks like so
doesn't take a genius to figure out that
something's wrong here
the main thing that's wrong here you
might you might actually notice is you
can actually see that we have actually
drawing tails want to zoom in here
really fast you can see um but usually
we are actually drawn tails but they
seem to be 1x1 pixels what's wrong and
the thing that's wrong here is we
actually haven't converted from pixel
precision to tar precision so it's
rendering literally one tile per pixel
the reason this tile looks half alright
is because we've actually run out of a
64 by 64 size map we've just like run
out of it that's why it looks okay um or
or rather we've run out of the screen
the screen resolution so that's why the
last tile is sort of like it's like in a
void so um but yeah the tiles are
clearly too small here so what went
wrong and if we go into our level glass
so you can actually see that well what
we did over here is we converted it into
you know tile precision but when we
render obviously our renderer you know
it needs to give the back into pixel
precision to render because we're
rendering individual pixels around not
piles like dren rutile we need to
actually render 16 pixels by 16 pixels
so if we actually go into our get tiles
render method and we just go into our
grass tile for example you'll see that
screen don't render tiles improve simply
rendering X&Y but remember that the s
and y variables that we inputted right
of here which is over here in our render
X Y there was simply detail precision
sprites oh sorry not sprites um tile
precision um integers so over here we
need to convert these back into armed
back into inter pixel precision before
we actually rendered them so over here
I'm simply going to do the opposite of
divided by 16 I'm going to multiply by
16 and to do that I'm simply going to
shifted left by 4 okay because that is
the exact same as doing that it's just
faster because it's a binary operation
and you know there's no need to actually
multiply by 16 if we can do that and
that is that's that's that okay one
other thing we need to do is do the same
thing for our void tile obviously so
we're here in the void tile we'll just
multiply both x and y by 16 that's it
let's run it look at that beautiful
we've got a map now if I actually just
move you can see that well we've got a
few things wrong here um first of all
you know you can actually see the tiles
being being drawn which is really cool
and I'll talk about that in a minute but
the other thing is um now that's
probably about it uh yet um what the
other thing that you can see is the you
know we're actually scrolling through a
map so it's not like one it's not like
the maps the size of the screen which is
what it was before now actually you can
see that where I'm
crashing festival that's alright
I just have to remember not to go out of
bounds map yet because we haven't
handled that um but um yeah you can see
that we're actually scrolling through a
map that is 64 by 64 sides maps is
divided by 64 tiles and you can see that
um it's you know it's random actually
every time we launch it and the way that
is getting generated obviously that's
saying one and basically one and four
tiles are going to be grass so yeah you
can see how that's sort of working out
now this blue it's obviously the void
tile because we actually made the void
tell blue if you remember in your in
sprite we actually made the fight I love
this color
which is you know the word sprite this
color which is blue um so yeah but that
is our result so one thing I want to
talk about really quickly is this sort
of thing that you see here now this is
really cool
all right and you can see that I were
actually running pretty fast here I say
that just as the FPS drops but on or
about three and a half thousand FPS
which is very good um but yeah um what
we can sort of see here is this this
black border I guess we see here and
it's basically I uh I think you might
have actually noticed last time on our
last time but like when I was actually
doing this run a tile method I I said
that I would deliberately make this
break method do what it did just to show
you guys the effect and that is the
effect you can see that as I scroll
right for example you can actually see
how this tile how this this like why um
you know the placement of tiles sort of
disappears and then this one appears
because what we're doing is we're only
rendering what is what is visible to the
player we're only rendering what's on
our screen we're not rendering stuff
that's not we're only rendering the
stuff that is on our screen which is
very beautiful so you can see sort of
how it's doing that it's it's it's
removing these tiles from the render
queue and it's putting these tiles into
the render queue as we approach them now
obviously we sort of need to offset this
by 1 tile so that we actually don't see
this flickering but that is the idea of
how it works and that's what you need to
do you only need to render what what you
see on the screen because if you don't
you know you're going to have major FPS
problems and this is actually what lets
us have our map infinite because you
know there's no reason why as soon as we
approach another area of the map why we
can't simply just load those tiles from
a file because I'm that's very fast and
that will result in an excellent
you know infinitely sized map pretty
much with um with no with no FPS with
the same FPS as we're having now so yeah
so yeah I hope you enjoyed this episode
of game programming guys if you did
please hit the like button and yeah next
time we'll probably take a look at
exciting this thing or we also need fix
the other problem which is crashing
because you can say that once we go out
of bounds which is about to happen
come on there we go once we go out of
balance so in other words we've reached
the end of the vertical size and now
remember the map is 64 by 64 tiles you
can see that we actually crash with the
rain with an array index out of bounds
exception so we'll probably take a look
at fixing that
but until then guys good bye
[Music]